To build out our UI, let's start with
the wire frames for the main activity.
It displays a list of forecasts
where each item contains an icon,
a date, weather description, as well as
high and low temperatures for that day.
Since today's weather is probably
most relevant to the user,.
We give more prominence to it as the
list item compared to the other dates.
We'll start off by building the list
item layout for future dates because
it's simpler and then afterwards we'll
come back to do the today layout.
In the current implementation
the list item forecast layout xml.
Is a horizontal,
linear layout of four text views.
We'll need to modify the layout so
that it looks like this wire frame.
We should divide and
conquer until we can use the view group
layouts that we're familiar with.
Can you imagine how you'd break down
this UI into components that you
know how to build?
As a hint,
what if I draw these separators here?
Within those elements,
can you find a way to break it down
even further with view
groups you're familiar with?
You'll need nested view groups
which means view groups
with children view groups.
By the way, use the view id names that
we provide in the instructor notes below
so that your code will match ours.
To verify that the layout
is being built correctly,
hard code some text
values into the fields.
Such as tomorrow for the date, or
clear for the weather condition.
For images, we can specify a placeholder
drawable called ic_launcher.
It's named this way because
it's the launcher icon.
Which is also known as the app icon and
this is already included in our app.
We'll be getting to the rest
of the weather icons for
our app later in this lesson.
If you want to see what
this layout looks like,
you can click on the design
pane to see a preview of it.
On the right we see a component tree
listing out the different views.
We can also see for a given view what
the properties are and their values.
We can change the orientation of
the device that you're previewing.
You can also select different devices,
such as Nexus 7 or Nexus 10.
You can also preview multiple
devices at the same time.
As you build out your layout for this
task, don't worry about the font color
or font size, or
any other visual details until later.
After you compile and run,
the app should look something like this.
Every list item has the same dummy data.
When you change the layout,
it will actually cause a crash in your
app because your code previously assumed
that this list item layout
only had one text view.
So you'll need to go to
the ForecastAdapter.java file.
And comment out the lines of
code in the bindview method.
We're going to fix this
method in a later video.